every data scientist has different
preferences when it comes to their
programming environment VIN versus Emacs
tabs versus spaces virtual M versus
anaconda today I want to share with you
my environment for working with data and
doing machine learning you most
definitely do not need to copy my setup
but perhaps some bits of it can serve as
a useful inspiration for your
development environment to start with we
need to talk about pip pip is pythons
package manager it has come built into
Python for quite a while now so if you
have Python you likely have pip already
pip installs packages like tensorflow
and numpy pandas and jupiter and many
many more along with their dependencies
many python resources are delivered in
some form of pip packages sometimes you
may see a file called requirements txt
in someone's folder of Python scripts
typically that file outlines all of the
pip packages that that project uses so
you can easily install everything needed
by using pip installed - our
requirements txt as part of this
ecosystem there's a whole world of
version numbers and dependencies I
sometimes need to use different versions
of a given library for different
projects that I'm working on so I need a
way to organize my groups of packages
into different isolated environments
there are two popular options currently
for taking care of managing your
different PI pip packages virtual end
and anaconda virtual imp is a package
that allows you to create named virtual
environments where you can install pip
packages in an isolated manner this tool
is great if you want to have detailed
control over which packages use install
for each environment you create for
example you could create an environment
for web development with one set of
libraries and a different environment
for data size this way you won't need to
have unrelated libraries interacting
with each other and it allows you to
create environments dedicated to
specific purposes now if you're
primarily doing data science work
anaconda is also a great option anaconda
is created by continuum analytics and it
is a Python
distribution that comes pre-installed
with lots of useful Python libraries for
data science anaconda is popular because
it brings many of the tools used in data
science and machine learning with just
one install so it's great for having a
short and simple setup like virtual and
anaconda also uses the concept of
creating environments so as to isolate
different libraries and versions
anaconda also introduces its own package
manager called Conda from where you can
install libraries
additionally anaconda still has the
useful interaction with pip that allows
you to install any additional libraries
which are not available in the anaconda
package manager so which one do I use
Virtual Earth or anaconda
well I often find myself testing out new
versions of tensorflow and other
libraries across both python 2 and
python 3 so ideally I would like to be
able to try out different libraries on
both virtual and and anaconda but
sometimes those two package managers
don't necessarily play nicely with each
other on one system so I have opted to
use both but I managed the whole thing
using a library called PI NF
conceptually PI M sits atop both virtual
imp in anaconda and it can be used to
control not only which ritual and
environment or anaconda environment
isn't use but it also easily controls
whether I'm running Python 2 or Python 3
one final aspect of Pi M that I enjoy is
the ability to set a default environment
for a given directory this causes that
desired environment to be automatically
activated when I enter the rectory I
find this to be way easier and trying to
remember which environment I want to use
every time I work on a project so which
package manager do you use it really
comes down to your workflow and
preferences if you typically just use
the core data science tools and are not
concerned with having some extra
libraries installed that you don't use
anaconda can be a great choice since it
leads to a simpler workflow for your
needs and preferences but if you're
someone who loves to customize your
environment and make it exactly like how
you want it then perhaps something like
virtual lab or even
maybe more to your liking there's no one
right way to manage Python libraries and
there's certainly more out there than
the options that I just presented as
different tools come and go it's
important to remember that everyone has
different needs and preferences so
choose for yourself what tools out there
serve you best so what does your Python
environment look like how do you keep it
from getting out of control
share your setup in the comments below
thanks for watching this episode of
cloud AI adventures be sure to subscribe
to the channel to catch future episodes
as they come out